baby-faced so you have nice cheeks oh I
think you just came out recently do have
a real Korean face huh
yeah I'm pretty kooky dude no that's
what I mean no no straight up though if
you if I something about you have my
cousin Paul's kind of eyes there's a
good thing in your eyes that's like very
Korean I can't explain it
I have a very Korean faces yeah yeah
you're a typical Korean you know my
friend did that was really disastrous to
her face and I think that she regrets it
but I don't have the heart to tell her
she got the double eyelid surgery she's
Korean oh yeah but it made her look
fully a hundred fifty percent cross-eyed
it exposed her actual yeah it revealed
what it was underneath which was that
she's actually a friend every day you
see them no I try to look at her stories
and I'm like dear God and then I have
myself a good laugh and then I asked my
Jessica my best friend I was like dude
like check this out and Jessica's like
well you should do you got to tell her
I'm like it she can't undo her eyes can
she I think you can do it that's a
really painful process though like I
hear like you there's a long healing
time probably but if you're ugly as [ __ ]
from that you might as well just get I
mean like that's pretty bad
oh so would you ever get it done no I
don't need any surgery so if I said to
you David my cousin is the best plastic
surgeon and in Beverly Hills did you
hear me out he really is he does the
Kardashians he does he did Kaitlyn's
[ __ ] to addiction good he's the best he
did blindfold
he did amazing that's a video dude wrong
- Oh perfect penis to vagina
perfect that's amazing he does eyes as
well okay yeah
and he takes [ __ ] eyes and makes them
look American right man they're gonna be
round and they're gonna be perfect and
guess what he generally charged she
charged Lucy Liu 3 million right to make
her eyes smaller to make them bigger and
he'll do use four
three let's do it absolutely not why
because I don't like changing I don't I
don't like plastic surgery's not my [ __ ]
I like I think plastic surgery's like
acceptable for people who are just
hideous like they in terms of societal
societal hideous you know I mean yeah
like that's just my thing like let's say
the jaw is off to the left and right
right like so if you were let me see
something if you were like you know
fiery accident yeah right and your face
was all bacon it's not gonna make a
difference I'm gonna be ugly either way
at that point no if I say there's the
surgery that's gonna make you look like
more Tom Cruise either or like were you
just literally rip somebody's face off
and put it to mine yeah yeah it's like
um Cruz died I could Tom's [ __ ] face
would really look like an alien
oh this is like 5:1 isn't he yes face
would you would be good on yours I know
Kathy Bates so I said hey yo dude your
face Kathy Bates just died same skull
that's crazy I'm gonna die with would
you do it I'm gonna do it I don't give a
[ __ ] about an Oscar dude all right
all right let me give it another name
then I know that's bigger George Foreman
I think George Foreman 100% you jerk
George Foreman's because it's hilarious
oh yeah oh you would look so weird oh
really but the face size makes sense
yeah so there wouldn't be any like no
coverage you know whose face you
couldn't replace look at how wide that
[ __ ] faces no you have the widest
it's very it's very Lego yeah it's very
Lego yeah yeah oh it's very Lego dude
yeah yeah but it's chiseled though the
Filipinos have massive faces though yes
my face is big I'm team big face I've
always been you know what I would do
with you go to Mount Rushmore and just
get one of those presidents faces off
you get Lincoln
how about they're just chiseling away
all right no Gilbert loves his face up
just
[Music]